the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so I'm sitting here in Kim boundaries'
office and actually Kim was the very
first person who got what I was trying
to do I when I knocked on his door
basically isn't that right basically
knocked on your door and said can I
please come here and make science
pictures this was in 1994 you were the
director of the new Edgerton Center that
just formed and you said sure you know
let's give it a shot and I just started
making more science pictures and that
kind of grew into something more
wonderful here at MIT so thanks Kim for
giving us some time and we're really
eager to see this little story about doc
and certainly about the pictures that he
made what he's known for and some of
your pictures to be fun to tell a bit of
a story for us thank you i'm really
looking forward to talking with you it
should be a lot of fun you bet so what
drew me to the Edgerton Center is that
people knew about it and that's really
where very exciting photography of
science was taking place and so it was a
natural place for me to at least start
right when i had the doc Edgerton
history and lots of famous photographs
yeah and she didn't know me from Adam I
mean I was did it right I mean jeez I
was just a director yes said your time
what gave me the impetus was that I had
been starting playing around and at
Harvard with George Whitesides work and
I did in fact have it a very small
portfolio of some pictures that I made
in a science lab so I had something to
show it wasn't that I just couldn't said
hire me no you'd had the
the white science fiction the Whitesides
archers and I think I might have had a
cover at that point I think you did you
had their you had the cover of the the
liquids on the hydrophobic and
hydrophilic surfaces you remember oh my
gosh yeah but still I I'll be forever
indebted to Kim for opening up the doors
that's basically what you did for me
that's what we intended to do that's
what the Edgerton Center was supposed to
be for so doc first published his
photographs in a book in the 1930s and
the first book was edited by Jim Killian
who at that time was the director of
Technology Review and he later became
the president of MIT alien okay yeah I
know that day that's a kill in and if
you'd notice even this book is this one
was not published in the late 70s and
again it's still at Edgerton and Killian
interest to kill and edited the first
three books with doc okay and where do
you come in there were like well and I
where I came in was I was a grad student
here for a year in 1968 when you come
here to MIT in the 60s you heard about
doc you know he was just in him he was a
phenomenon and at MIT but then I left
and went those two years in the Army and
I took up photography as a hobby and
develop my own built-in trang vietnam in
1970 a dark room for that anybody could
use but then develop my own color slides
while i was there kodachrome or a six I
would know the only thing couldn't have
been coded no I think it was the only
one that you could you know that that
you could get the process for i think
was ektachrome which which is e 6 yeah
and so that by both i built this photo
lab on my spare time and
in Vietnam in 1970 and taught myself to
develop color film which is a painful
process awful temperature controls and
all of that right so then I show up back
at MIT in January of 1972 and I'm facing
taking my doctor exams to qualify for
the ph.d program and I was taking all
these hard drury subjects to prepare and
I wanted to do one thing for fun and so
I went and knocked on Doc's door didn't
know him but told him about what I had
been doing and said I really want to
learn how to do strobe photography can I
take your undergraduate course and he
said you know sure will let anybody in
and everybody just even yeah yeah even
here and and so I i took the subject
that spring which is called straw
project lab which we still teach today
and I'd had I was a grad student and I
had had dozens of lab courses and so the
lab work was a lark him it was just fun
and I just had a blast and he needed a
TA the the following year and so hired
me to be his teaching assistant that's
when we really got to know what it's one
on a story a little like not quite our
story but I met you when I to dr. your
tour right same tour same glad I said
you know I'd really like to make science
pictures and you said we'll take anybody
and at that point you you'd you were
terrific you just said yeah let's see
what we could do and I just expanded
through the years and well and that's
that's the spirit of doc that I wanted
to have in what we called the Edgerton
Center doin doc diet in January Becky 90
I proposed to MIT that we as a legacy to
doc we turn his laboratory into a place
where MIT student could come knocking on
the door and get help to be able to
pursue hands-on experiential projects
that they wanted to do and that was the
essentially that really beginning that
was the beginning
and with the Edgerton Center was
formally founded in August of 92 and so
now we're 20 / pushing forty five years
that's right you might have a
celebration at some point yes we are
yeah we had to think about that so we
were almost 25 years old and we still
and I the initial vision was to have it
continue to be a go-to place for know
how in high-speed photography so we
continue to teach the subjects we
continue to do a professional
development course in the summer and
it's the go-to places so we hoped yet we
to try to do can still do that and then
but we also wanted to help MIT students
who had projects that they wanted to
work on outside of the classroom and so
today the way that is embodied in the
Edgewood centers we sponsor about a
dozen student clubs and teams that build
stuff so the solar electric vehicle team
and underwater autonomous vehicle team
Formula SAE robotics aerial vehicles Wow
a team that rides coast to coast called
spokes that stops with a ride bikes
across the country in the summertime
stopping along the way to teach middle
school lessons in science oh man it's a
wonder let's turn to some of the docs
pictures all right and maybe if we can
concentrate on what have become iconic
in a way if this is your story where
we're looking at books on the desk and
Kim is going to look with me at some
images and I might ask some questions
we'd like to teach our students taking
our course we'd like to introduce them
to some of the techniques we don't want
to go too deeply because we're not
actually doing this in this course but I
think I felt it was important for them
to be aware of this kind of photography
for later on maybe right I the I thought
mostly what I would talk about did
doesn't actually have a lot to do with
high-speed techniques it has more to do
with why I was a doc a great
photographer okay great it's good and
that's that's relevant to all of
anybody's absolutely so I'm going to do
it a little bit chronologically that's a
um a dot was fascinated with liquids and
water and taking pictures of those
things for some reason very early on and
he claims the very first picture that he
took of that wasn't of an electric motor
and he was taking pictures of electric
motors because that was his PhD thesis
and he needed the strobe to help him
understand motors he claimed the first
picture they took we using a flash of
something else was water coming out of a
faucet and for the rest of his life he
took pictures of water doing it waters
tricky it's hard to take pictures of it
and one of the thin his iconic
photograph is the crown splashed called
the Coronet the splash of the milk drop
and the original black and white of it
which we're looking at right here was
included in the first ever photographic
exposition at the Museum of Modern Art
wow I just before that they didn't
consider photography art yeah okay yeah
but it's there it's in the collections
and was nineteen like 1937 hmm so
there's that picture and that's liquid
again but really an amazing picture that
nobody had ever seen before because
really good stop motion pictures had
existed before but actually in fact
that's a lie i went back recently and
did a little work because I help with
somebody giving a talk in Cambridge and
there's some pictures of splashes of
milk drops that go back to about the
turn of the century I know and I
forgotten the name of the guy who did it
I I wrote it down somewhere I just saw
it at the Victoria yeah no sorry I saw
at the London said you got yeah it was
Ben that's right yeah and ice I just saw
it a month ago I said wait a second yeah
that's before doc yeah that's right so I
think I think doc had to have known
that was in season but the fellow who
had done them this was before good
electronic triggering and this is about
all I'll say about high speed
photography the key to high-speed
photography is to have a very short
duration flash but to have a way of
knowing when to make it go up that's it
in the trade we call that triggering how
do you trigger that flash to make it go
off and the way you take a bullet
picture is you use a microphone and once
when the shock wave from the bullet
passes the microphone the microphone
sets off the flash hmm and in the
darkened room you can look at where the
bullets supposed to be you shoot the gun
the flash goes off your eye sees exactly
where it is and if you want your picture
to have the bullet three inches to the
left you take the microphone which is
down below out of sight move it three
inches to the left to it again it's
exactly where you want it so triggering
is lot of the story about high speed
once you have a source of a high-speed
flash so you're actually triggering the
light triggering the timing of the light
takes two things good timing and a very
short duration burst of light so the
inventor one of the two inventors of
photography was William Henry Fox Talbot
and in 1859 he took a flash picture so
the first / photograph is 1859 and it
was an air gap spark of a capacitor
discharge and it was a piece of
newspaper spinning on a disk oh wow so
flash photography goes back a long way
do I remember correctly that he tried it
with water and eventually decided I
don't know my guess is he I'm sure he
tried it with one yes that in fact my
guess is he saw it in water yeah and he
said oh that is cool how do we we can't
really do it so is this just milk if
yeah they actually use I know they use
milk early honor court melter and sour
and we'll have it not very long and so
pretty soon after that they figured out
how to do it fake milk okay so that
would last a little bit longer so that
picture then was taken into in the
mid-30s and then one color film came out
then doctor took the picture again in
color and that's the iconic one and read
that post cards every part I sort of
liked this one better myself yeah I mean
I'll tell a lot of stories a couple of
the other stories about doc he knew he
had a good thing but the world didn't
know he had a good thing and he went to
Kodak in and said you know you ought to
make a product out of this and sell
cameras with flash units with electronic
flash and at that time people were using
flash bulbs and they said well we looked
into it we figured we could sell about
50 units a year to just isn't worth it
and so then this is probably this is in
the forties and I set out then to prove
them wrong and to generate so much
demand that they could mean art and so
we started building the first portable
units battery-operated equipped sports
photographers with portable units drink
and so there's a picture I didn't dig
out today it's in the Boston Garden and
it's an indoor track meet and it's a
runner coming around the curve and it's
just absolutely crisp stop motion shot
of this guy and it was the first
high-speed flash sports photograph to go
out on AP wire photo/eric and then then
after that there's a another fantastic
image so doc he said I'm going to you
know prove him wrong I got to show
people that this is the way to do it and
the other picture that I didn't pull out
today is the absolutely classic sports
shot which is the knockout punch from
Jill oh yeah that's your lewis hook shot
which is when that went out on AP and
that was a magic show stopper picture ok
there we go and that
isn't the chilean arturo godoy in 1940
can you imagine seeing something like
that for the first time yeah a whole new
world so it didn't take too many
pictures like that and the better you
need this the photography industry
started to say oh this is there
something important here right so then
he got fascinated really fascinated with
speed and what would impress people more
than to be able to stop a bullet in
flight I think that doc just said we got
to do that and so he took lots of bullet
features so people know pictures of
bullets through Apple's and write all
sorts of things and people are doing it
in classes yeah we do it every we teach
our own sure students how to take a
bullet picture every year because they
ditch this I want it cool alright but
the picture that I pull it out to talk
about is a picture that has three
balloons in a row with a bullet passing
one after another through the third and
so the first one is in almost complete
disintegration the second one is
partially gone and the third one has
just barely shown the effects of being
shot this essentially in a single
photograph with a single flash of light
does a wonderful job of showing the
passage of time so I think this is just
brilliantly crafted photograph to tell a
story in a single picture that's my boy
he was really cool added at that kind of
getting you got it so um very exciting
yeah that's indeed you have lots of
bullet pictures but I had this is one of
my favorites getting was so cleverly
done and this was before the development
of high speed multiple flash cameras so
dhakad his contribution to high-speed
photography was the perfection of two
things the electronic controls so you
had now you had transistors and modern
things that you could switch current
very quickly and also very short
duration sources of light and in
particular the Xenon flash tube which is
in every
camera that you buy hmm so he perfected
the Xenon flash tube which gives out
very bright daylight color spectrum
light in a very short duration around
what year are we talking about roughly
well I said well he started he there
were strobes available when he was doing
his PhD work in the late started by 1928
then these pictures like the the one in
the Museum of Modern Art early in mid
30s by that time I think he was using
xenon ok he was developing flash tube
technology back then and when I was a TA
in 1972 one of the labs that you did is
you you went in the lab it made your own
flash to me not really understood flash
tube technology he had just you had made
your own and so we had you know pyrex
glass and a glassblowing setup and you
took the glass and you you learned how
to embed electrodes in it to conduct the
electricity inside you filled it with
Xena at the right pressure and then you
pinched it off and you had your own tube
what talk about hands-on yeah yeah
that's what he was all when you took the
course in those days you tested flash
tubes you made your own and then you
went and you also then went took
pictures of bullets in had to do a
project of your own that was it was
called strobe project lab in the second
half of the course you had to choose
something of your own to do and so
students by that time had pushed
multiple pianos off the top of dorms and
taking pictures of them and stuff like
that but I was an ocean engineer and I
took on a project of taking high speed
technical photographs for quantitative
purposes of propellers and a water
tunnel pics propellers under certain
conditions generate bubbles and you may
see this helix going downstream and it's
called cavitation color cavitate it
erodes it very fast and damages at
entity or submarine it makes it renders
amount of noise it makes it
to detect you so cavitation is important
but pictures of things with bubbles
around them in water actually kind of
hard to take so we have a propeller
tunnel here in the ocean engineering
department and they had been taking
pictures in it but they weren't very
good and so I actually took a lot of
pictures and then wrote the manual on
how to actually take good fantastic so
that was my which I think it's still in
the drawer over there they said lighting
is the most critical part white bubbles
reflect so much and the windows you got
to take pictures through windows which
is a problem right major problem yeah
right so you learn all about how to take
the things that reflect on you and
bubbles reflect light crazy so getting
the lighting the exposure correct is
yeah we talked we talked a lot about
that the thing doc was of you know an
opportunist but he was very also very
creative and another thing that doc did
he was an MIT professor and to this day
high-speed photography's probably
greatest uses in industrial settings doc
soon was sought out by people in
industry to use high-speed photography
to troubleshoot and so he actually all
through his life he did a lot of what
turned out to be really interesting
consulting jobs so he was always
carrying his camera and he would take
pictures of opportunities we thought
they were is really cool pictures and
this is one of my favorite ones this
shows a mill worker sometime in the
nineteen thirty-seven and it was
probably this is the paper mill and
paper mills are notorious for a thing
you know have you ever seen a newspaper
being printed or something like that the
papers just screaming across rollers at
very high speed and if something goes
wrong you get an enormous mess in a
hurry and it's going so fast papers
moving so fast you can't see with your
eye what the problem is and so Doc's new
high-speed photography was a real
blessing for people in industry with
things that were very high speed and
could get in trouble so but this is an
example of that he was no doubt
working on a consulting job you see in
the background you can see these big
rolls of paper that are going through
this meal he had probably been taking
very technical pictures probably trying
to get them to understand something and
then he saw this fellow this worker with
a pitchfork with this enormous mass of
trimmings off the edges of paper roll
forking this big like hey but it's not
hey it's paper but you know it's a
beautiful it's wonderful and so his just
sense of seeing a good picture and say
I've got to do this and then his
craftsmanship at being able to make it a
great picture not just an ordinary what
kind of camera was he like you this was
probably a four by five okay he did a
lot of used a lot of four by five I've
forgotten the term I haven't used when I
saw it sir yeah you know you put with
the back on it you put it in and pull
the slide out and took a picture which
is considerably cumbersome dude this is
that without a tripod yeah I guess is I
don't know yeah he would also then he
would just carry along a 35-millimeter
what camera was available at the time
just to be able to take set of pictures
and quick site but when he then really
want a good picture he'd get out the old
four by five man he put it on a tripod
if he had one there and they do it right
this is a big version of this picture in
the hallway oh that's how you are you're
standing almost in front of it out oh ok
so that's one of my favorite dr.
opportunity kind of pictures but that
came from his consulting ah yes so
what's that stone head but wow what is
it yeah it's a WoW picture of Stonehenge
there was another opportunity he had to
plan this rather carefully there's a
sister picture to this that's upstairs
and if we go upstairs you can see it
it's this dull looking why do you bother
to put that image on the wall picture
but this photograph is taken at midnight
there abouts and the sister companion
picture that goes with it is a
photograph from a night reconnaissance
aircraft the the pilots are learning are
practicing for taking photo
using brand new Edgerton strobe
equipment to take photographs of
Normandy anjuna 1944 so this is leading
up to that they've installed these are
brand new electronic means of taking
reconnaissance photographs and put them
in US Army Air Force airplanes and are
teaching the pilots to do it prior to
the use of flash you would have one
plane fly over at high altitude like
five or ten thousand feet and drop
flares on parachutes and then the
reconnaissance plane would have to fly
in at 1,500 feet illuminated backlit by
the flares so that people would guns
could see it and so it was really
dangerous work and then you'd fly over
with the lights and the flares taken the
pictures but also getting shot at so
that's it had been the standard way to
do reconnaissance photographs the Army
Air Force came to him early in the war
and said can we use your Flash
technology to take pictures at nighttime
and so they just started developing
really powerful flashes so your typical
camera flash might be 5 watt seconds of
energy that's a minnow measure of
electrical power so 5 so by the end of
the war Edgerton flash units that were
being carried in reconnaissance aircraft
were 50,000 watt seconds ya can't even
imagine and there there's a movie one of
the movies about doc it shows him in our
classroom and he's got a yard stick with
a sheet of newspaper taped to a hanging
from it and he's standing about far from
you to hear so the 50,000 watt second
flash unit as a reflector about this big
around and I've been a flash tube with
the xenon in it as a coil of helix about
this big around and you shoot it off and
that piece of newspaper just bursts into
flames that's how much heat is coming
off of this thing with the light so
these they were installing the units
they wanted to send the pilots out to
practice with it and he said let's take
a picture of Stonehenge and so he was on
the ground
and he said his four by five camera on a
fence post and he knew when they were
coming and he used to open the shutter
and waited for the night reconnaissance
food this is the wait are you telling me
the light was coming of life comes from
the airplane and it it traveled that far
well it had it was so strong it would so
that because the airplanes trying to
take a picture of what's on the ground
so the photograph that's upstairs is the
photograph of Stonehenge taken by the
aircraft oh so you can see the aircraft
photograph this is the companion
photograph that goes with it that's
absolutely fabulous so taking
photographs of things that wartime is
pretty commonplace but knowing to be
here with your forget where oh yeah it's
post and get this image that no one else
before or since has been a day that's
absolutely them so this is a you know
just show see ya release SFO's a
photographer so I really love that
picture then yeah this is the more
recent typical bullet through Apple
making applesauce stocks comment was you
know it takes takes a micro second take
the picture in all morning to clean up
and so I was his teaching assistant in
73 74 in this subject we called Stroh
project lab and he was exactly my age
now when I was working for him he was he
had just retired he was 69 retirement
meant to him that he got to keep his lab
but he didn't he only had to do what he
wanted to do basically he was so
important to mi dia de he said look I
tell you what I'll stop drawn salary but
you let me keep my lap and they said
fine and so he kept coming to work every
day until nineteen ninety so this was 19
this was 1972 so I had been in the class
in the spring in the summertime had
talked to him and found out it needed a
TA I was a doctoral student in ocean
engineering in May of 72 I did pass the
exams and my one fun thing for the term
would been taking the high-speed
photography course and doc and I agreed
that i'd be the TA and the fall and so I
showed up
and you know about labor day and there
was a litter waiting for me and the
letter said doc says sorry I can't be
there kid my mother my mother's not
feeling well and at the time I said you
know he's 69 years old your mother's not
fan she was 98 or something like that
and he was off visiting with her in
Nebraska and he said beasts as well yet
I'd like you to think about working on a
project while you're my ta that's kind
of unusual t8 you know are usually
grades the lab books it helps in the lab
but you don't do some research that as
well doc says why don't you do a project
and he says I've never done colors
lehren photography now schlieren
photography had already been used for
many many years in the aircraft industry
to take photographs of aircraft models
in supersonic speeds because at
supersonic speed you everybody knows
about sonic booms you have a shock wave
that comes off of the aircraft and the
shockwave is a high-intensity sound wave
and the aircraft industry you could
study the shock waves in a wind tunnel
if you had a photographic technique that
would make shock waves of visible so it
was called schlieren and they did it in
black and white and there were a few few
color techniques but axes so I've done
stand before but I've never done color
Sharon why don't you see if you can do
that so that was September I went to the
library found four different ways of
doing klaren photography in color in all
the technical journals built my first
setup took my first pictures you know
doc has come back by now and and I take
him into him and he takes out his 10
power loop which he always carried with
him any holes we hold to 35 millimeter
film up and he looked at me as a ban
looked a little out of focus all right
God and which wasn't because I couldn't
focus a camera but was that just was the
nature of that particular method is
really so then I'd went back to the
library and built another system and who
did it differently and why yeah I'm
walking in a couple weeks later and show
Doc the pictures and remember the hit
this is color black and white was easy
and sure
this was color so they walk in and it
Brad I don't like the color okay so bye
so how do you have to understand that
one of the reasons it took so long as
you get this the system set up it takes
some black-and-white pictures just to
make sure is looking okay because you
could take three or four frames of 35
millimeter black and white film walk
across to the the photo lab develop it
right on the spot and hold it up wet to
see what you got and if it looked right
then you went back across the hall put
the color film in the camera took a
whole roll of pictures and then set it
off and waited a week ah in 1972 you had
to wait a week I remember those days
it's called film rights film and not
instant film neither right anyway and it
took a week to get him back so that that
was all part of the process so it wasn't
until December so I was getting pretty
frustrated and I found an article in
Scientific American and there was a
fellow by the names of cl stong who for
decades had a column in Scientific
American called the amateur scientist
and it was basically the do-it-yourself
science column inside every American and
he would accept contributions from
people and choose which ones he liked
then each month there'd be another you
know build your own radio or do this or
do that and there was an article on a
new way to do color sermon and had been
developed by a graduate student at the
university of tennessee guy by the name
of Gary settles and he hadn't done
high-speed photography part that he had
come up with a better way to do the
color so I built that and I took the
pictures and I had three or four of them
and I think one of the earliest pictures
I took was very much like this one and I
walked into the docs office one morning
and a handed them to 35 millimeter color
slide and he looks up and he says van I
think you've got oh my gosh
hallelujah you must have felt every
october november december january whoa
but then once we had it once he saw a
picture like yes he knew we had it and
so then he dissin courage me to take
pictures of everything under the sun and
so we just tried all sorts of stuff so
what we're seeing am i right we're
seeing changes in index of refraction
yeah so color flarin allows you to see
changes in index in a transparent medium
so water air anything that light will
pass through you can take a picture a
picture of it so this is a candle this
is just the ordinary hot air above a
candle which you normally can't see
except as kind of a mirage in fact you
know like when you're looking at a
highway in the desert and here's this is
a 22 caliber bullet and this is the
shockwave that accompanies it and the
nice thing about shock waves is they
make kind of a V and the angle of the be
1 over the sine of this angle is the
Mach number I know if that angles 30
degrees sine of 30 is a half won over a
half is to that bullet is traveling up
to or twice as vsm that's analyst so in
pictures like this there's a lot of
really interesting fun physics and
things to talk about the color in this
particular slurring technique the color
you see tells you the direction in which
the light was refracted so this is a
little bubble I know just a ball of hot
air it's hottest in the center and it's
cooling radially in all directions the
temperatures are dropping so the the
index of refraction is increasing
radially in all directions so if the
light ray goes into the upper part here
it is light bends toward increasing
index up here the light was bent up here
was bent to the right here it was bent
to the left and in there was bent down
so up his yellow down his blue left his
green right his
yeah so this this is highly information
lots of a lot of really something to
look at so you and then you look at a
picture like this you can see the candle
thing nicely yes now that's that's a
self-illumination that that light is
coming from the flame the light that
took the rest of the picture is coming
from the ear high-speed source which is
a third of a micro second in duration
which allows you to stop bullet in its
tracks but the light to get the candle
flame comes from the candle flame itself
but if you only had the shutter open a
third of a microsecond that's not enough
lighting the candle flame so in fact the
way you take the picture is you turn off
all the lights in the room you open the
shutter on the camera four quarter maybe
half a second and when the person on the
gun here's the shutter click they pull
the trigger the bullet travels across
the system the microphone senses the
microphones sitting right here by the
way you can see the shockwave just right
down here out of sight is the microphone
shockwave hits a microphone microphone
sets off the flash takes a picture so
the flash is a third of a micro second
duration and that's how long that's the
exposure time for everything you see
here but the but the shutters been open
half a second and so you have a half a
second exposure time of the candle flame
so they're always blurry because they
flicker you and the shots shores by and
he got past that right oh yeah well and
that's a sparkler so if you knew what
your shutter time was your exposure time
let's say it was an eighth of a second
or something or maybe less these little
trails are the sparks you could figure
out how fast they're going oh gosh of
course I said you know how long this is
then a time exposure of the trail of
spark as it travels through the air like
subatomic particles yeah it's a good way
in a way it's yeah kind of like a smoke
be no I smoke chamber so actually here's
one of my favorite pictures of my own
stuff
and i'll talk about both of these this
is a picture just of a soap bubble in
just about life size and soap bubbles in
Clarence systems turn out to be really
interesting you see things you don't
normally see so this is a rubber hose
that was dumped in the soap solution
then you blow on the end of the hose to
make the bubble these are little
streamers of soapy solution that are
actually flowing on the surface of the
bubble and they do most interesting
things they go along and then they
divide and divide again and a movie of
this is just fascinating you can in a
picture like this if you look carefully
you can actually see this is shockwave
but that's reflected shock wave that has
actually hit the rubber hose and bounced
off and down here there's a arc that's
sound that's really reflected off the
bubble so bubbles were a lot of fun and
then this picture is fun in in a sense
in that doc took this picture in another
form many many years before so that's a
1930s it's an old house fan and the it's
spinning and then up just above it is
artificial smoke especially if M achill
smoke and as the propeller blade passes
by off the tip of any surface it's
generating lift there is a vortex and
he's put the smoke there so it gets
sucked into the vortex and shut down
stream as a helix and so in this picture
you can see that vortex forming in the
smoke and this is the same photograph
with the Sam fan the same because he
still added around the lab in Schlereth
the right picture has the disaster
travel fan this one I said this is an
alcohol lamp and you could not usually a
little tiny blue flame this just hot air
the hot air is being sucked into the
vortex and then is shut down here's the
here's the helix that's this a core of
vorticity that goes off this way so
there's another one of the subjects that
we took a trip so social Aaron
photographs were a lot of fun and then
there the story of the
there's one other bit a story that is
appropriate to a course where you're
teaching grad students and that sort of
thing about taking photographs this
picture doc really likes and he said
okay Kimmy says you need to write a
paper and then we're going to go to this
conference and show your stuff give this
paper at the 11th international congress
on high-speed photography in London and
I think the summer of 1973 so I had this
venue where doc was the grand old man he
was the father of modern high speed
photography it was at University College
London they filled the auditorium and
all these old Pete cronies that were
friends of DOC that he'd worked with
through the war and afterwards he was
famous with these people so here I was
getting to you know under his wing
getting to go everywhere he went and
treated like royalty so I gave my paper
showed 30 or 40 of these beautiful color
images that people hadn't seen before
but he had also taken about a dozen
pictures had them enlarged like 16 by 20
sent them ahead and they'd all been set
up in a gallery so that anybody coming
through the place could walk through
this gallery and see all these
photographs so while I was there this
fellow comes up to me and he said really
like your photographs he said I'd like
to to use them I said okay and so this
picture was a cover photograph on nature
magazine oh gosh so this was my first
professional publication and addressed
was his little short article in nature
with the motor private on the cover what
year yeah 74 yeah let's copy of it
that's exciting but that was dad talking
about how you know I get it you know to
get to have to have your first
publication when you're when you're
applying as a professor or something
somewhere to be cover photograph of
nature has a pretty good place to start
really good hey this is great Oh Kim
thank you this is a wonderful wonderful
story not that so that was my first
professional publication as a graduate
student and was a nice thing to have on
on my resume going forward I've said
many times I wouldn't be here today if I
hadn't had that experience with doc
Edgerton the even though i was an ocean
engineer and i didn't continue
professionally as you know in high-speed
photography as his mentee what it did
for me is the year i worked for him as a
teaching assistant was a year I was not
doing something in ocean engineering and
that was because I hadn't found a thesis
topic that I really liked and it gave me
a year of extra time that I could go do
something fantastically fun and find a
great thesis topic so by the end of that
year I not only got to give this paper
but I had had come up with a super
thesis topic which then that opened the
door ways for me to becoming a professor
of ocean engineering timing yeah timing
a little luck and a non-title afraid
knock on the door there you go thank you
exactly right good job Kim yeah thank
you